en este vídeo vamos a calcular el
resultado de multiplicar 592 por 7 pero
en general vamos a pensar en cómo
podemos obtener la multiplicación de un
número con varios dígitos por un número
que tiene un solo dígito si le preguntas
a tus padres es muy probable que esta
sea la forma como ellos multiplican así
que la forma estándar para multiplicar
es primero escribes el número con más
dígitos en la parte superior y después
escribes el número de un solo dígito
debajo de él en su respectivo valor
posicional entonces pondremos al 7 en la
columna de las unidades por debajo del 2
de 592 en la columna de las unidades no
olvidemos poner el signo de la
multiplicación
y ahora la forma de hacerlo será
multiplicar todos los valores
posicionales de este número de varios
dígitos por 7 por ejemplo tomamos estas
dos unidades o dos unos y los
multiplicamos por 7 entonces obtenemos
14 unidades o 14 unos pero como no hay
un solo dígito para 14 unos entonces
pondré 4 de esos unos aquí en esta
columna de las unidades y los otros 10
unos que nos faltan lo puedo expresar
como una decena así que lo pondré aquí
arriba
algunas veces cuando las personas
aprenden de esta forma de multiplicar se
les dice 2 por 7 es igual a 14 escribes
4 y llevas 1 aunque realmente lo que
está sucediendo es bueno 14 es lo mismo
que una decena más 4 unos bien ahora
vamos a movernos al lugar de las decenas
cuál es el resultado de 9 por 7 bueno 9
por 7 es lo mismo que 63 así que 9
decenas por 7 63 decenas más otra de
ellas que llevábamos es 64 decenas así
que pondremos cuatro de esas decenas
aquí y las otras sesenta decenas las
podemos expresar como seis centenas así
que pondré un 6 en esta columna
muchas personas explican esto de la
siguiente manera 9 763 más una que
llevábamos el 64 pongo el 4 y llevo 6
pero espero que este vídeo te ayude a
entender qué significa eso te llevaron a
acarrear estos números realmente lo que
intentas es escribir 64 decenas pero
como sólo 4 decenas se pueden escribir
en este espacio por cuestiones de orden
entonces las otras 60 decenas las
expresamos como 6 centenas y las
colocamos en la columna de las centenas
por último pero no por eso menos
importante 5 centenas por 7 es 35
centenas más 6 centenas que llevábamos
son 41 centenas y las escribir aquí
entonces nuestro resultado es 4 mil 144
ahora quiero que conectemos esta forma
de multiplicar cuando otras que tal vez
hayas visto así que volver a escribir
592 por 7 bueno una forma de calcular
esto en el pasado es decir que se
obtiene de 2 por 7 bueno eso será 14
observa es el mismo 14 que teníamos
antes pero lo estamos representando de
una manera distinta después decimos cuál
es el resultado de 9 por 7 que en
realidad es 9 decenas por 7 bueno eso es
63 decenas así que lo escribimos aquí o
dicho otra manera esto es lo mismo que
630 y por último calculamos 5 centenas
por 7 lo cuales 35 centenas entonces
podemos escribirlo de esta manera
escribo 35 centenas
es 3500 y el final sumamos todo tenemos
cuatro unidades cuatro decenas en total
tenemos once centenas al final así que
ponemos una centena aquí y reagrupamos
las otras diez centenas en el lugar de
las unidades de millar y una unidad de
millar más tres unidades de millar son
cuatro unidades de millar observa
obtenemos el mismo resultado porque
esencialmente hicimos lo mismo en el
primer procedimiento acarreamos o
llevamos números es decir reagrupamos de
una forma condensada lo que hicimos a la
derecha en el segundo procedimiento de
una manera sistemática multiplicamos 2
por 7 9 por 7 5 por 7 y nos aseguramos
de cuidar el orden de los lugares para
tratarlos como productos parciales tal
vez y al final los sumamos todo del lado
izquierdo acarreamos a lo largo del
procedimiento pero esencialmente
ocupamos los respectivos valores cuando
deseamos 2 unidades por 7 unidades eso
era lo mismo que 14 unidades que es lo
mismo que cuatro unidades más 10 y así
continuamos te encargo que aprendas este
método de multiplicar yo creo que es
bueno aprender este método ya que es la
forma más común para multiplicar insisto
es muy probable que tus padres
aprendieron de esta manera pero creo que
tiene más importancia que entiendas que
estas dos formas de multiplicar son
iguales reflexiona un poco todo esto
razona lo piensa si realmente entiendes
todo lo que pasa aquí y no intentes
memorizar todos los pasos nada más